[Music]
okay so I'm going to start in MATLAB and
we are going to to code this up so here
I have I hope I'm pretty consistent in
what my variables are called
I basically have just some random x
values and I have some B values which
are 0.9 times X plus some random noise
so here I should probably have done this
a little bit more carefully I should
have probably said a equals 0.9 and then
I would say B equals a times X plus some
random noise okay and if I don't have
any outliers I could do a pretty good
job of approximating the true slope with
least I should say this is really
important if this outlier wasn't here
these squares would do a great job if I
had Gaussian white noise if I had like
white noise measurement error but I had
a lot of data points and no outliers
least squares would do a really good job
but with the outlier it's gonna fail
okay so good and now here what I'm gonna
do is at the very last data point I'm
going to drop a massive outlier I'm just
gonna put a huge outlier in the data and
so I'm gonna plot this for you okay so
I'm gonna run this and I'm going to plot
the data and so you see here these these
kind of blue dots are the data with with
a small amount of noise and this red dot
here is this massive massive outlier
okay and we're gonna see when we do
least squares that this is gonna tilt
the whole distribution okay
this blue line here is the least squares
estimate if there was no outlier if you
remove that outlier then the least
squares estimate is pretty good okay but
now what we're going to do is we're
going to compute the El to fit this kind
of least squares solution with this big
outlier okay and again in MATLAB this is
really easy this is just the backslash
command you could also do pseudo inverse
there's lots of ways of doing this I
talked about this a lot in Chapter one
on the SVD so I'm going to run this and
that adds a data point
and now you can see that my sorry my
legends messed up but you can see that
my least squares fit now that I had this
outlier is really wrong I mean it is the
hole the hole fit is getting tilted down
so that I'm mitigating the effect of
this huge squared error between that
because of that one outlier okay so that
one outlier is messing it up for the
whole rest of the distribution in least
squares okay but this is solvable this
is a fixable problem and this is really
kind of neat is that you can also solve
for the solve for L one minute solution
and we're gonna do that again using CVX
this convex optimization toolbox you'll
have to download this and install it in
your MATLAB but it's pretty easy to do
so we are going to introduce this this
variable this kind of l1 minimum version
of a and we're going to minimize the one
norm of the error okay we're going to
basically over it we're gonna minimize
over a the one norm of the error okay
and I'm gonna run this it might take a
minute this always takes a minute to run
CVX that was pretty fast and I hope it
plotted my new fit perfect okay so now
when I inst when I swap out my two norm
for a one norm and I do the same
optimization now I get this white line
which is almost perfect it is almost
exactly where it should be
so it really has mitigated that effect
of that that single outlier so that
single outlier plagued my l2 my least
square solution that's red curve it was
terrible but when I use an l1 when I
minimize the l1 norm of the error it's
extremely robust to this big outlier and
it fixes the distribution back to where
it should be
okay so minimizing so you can add this
l1 norm you can minimize the l1 norm of
the error instead of the l2 norm and you
get this incredible robustness to
outliers so that is something everybody
should know this is absolutely critical
is that using the l1 norm makes you much
much more robust to outliers and this is
a problem we have
real-world data our data is almost never
perfectly clean with Gaussian white
noise we almost always have bad
measurements and outliers and corruption
and things like that and so this l1 norm
is kind of becoming more and more and
more popular as we get into real data
problems in data modeling okay thank you